yesterday was truly a day for the
history books in the United States there
aren't that many days every decade never
mind Century
um like what we saw yesterday the failed
former president Donald Trump was
arrested booked indicted and pleaded not
guilty for 37 felony counts was
instructed not to be in contact with any
other defendants nor Witnesses a
requirement which he immediately broke
last night Trump then flew back to his
Bedminster New Jersey Golf Resort I
think it is where he actually
admitted to some of the crimes that he
is accused of despite claiming total
innocence and claiming that he didn't do
anything and we now move into two
different new phases the pre-trial phase
with this latest Federal indictment as
well as the waiting game for what may be
a second Federal indictment for Trump's
role in the January 6th Trump riots and
a state indictment out of the state of
Georgia for Trump's attempt to
incorrectly fraudulently illegally
overturn the correct results from
Georgia in 2020 in which now President
Joe Biden won the popular vote of
Georgia and subsequently the electoral
votes from Georgia so let's start at the
beginning
the Miami Herald reporting Trump sits
silently in Miami courtroom pleads not
guilty in historic case former president
Donald Trump pleaded not guilty Tuesday
in Miami Federal Court to a 37-count
indictment accusing him of deliberately
keeping at his Palm Beach estate
government documents that contained
highly sensitive defense weapons and
nuclear information and of obstructing
efforts by U.S authorities to reclaim
them in a packed courtroom and remember
there were no cameras in the courtroom
so all we have are these descriptions in
a packed courtroom tremend Trump entered
his plea in a historic case marking the
First Federal prosecution of a former
president and a potential hurdle in his
renewed quest for the presidency in the
2024 election Trump's lawyer Todd
Blanche representing Trump alongside
Chris Keyes said quote we most certainly
enter a plea of not guilty Trump was
arraigned a day before his 77th birthday
that will be relevant later as well
appearing before Magistrate Judge
Jonathan Goodman Trump said nothing
during the 45-minute proceeding
prosecutor David harbach told the judge
his team would prepare a list of
witnesses with whom Trump cannot
communicate about the case before the
trial Trump was released on his own
recognizance with no monetary Bond and
no travel restrictions so I think it's
important to mention one of the reasons
that this indictment generally is
important
is that we want a justice system that
doesn't have exceptions where no one is
above the law and despite what you're
hearing from the magats magadonians uh
megapotamians whatever you want to call
them despite what you're hearing from
them that this is evidence of a
two-tiered justice system in a bad way
in fact we know we have a two-tier
justice system Trump being indicted is
maybe a slight half step in the
direction of no one is above the law
however there still are favoritisms that
are being given to Trump including the
fact that he was released on his own
recognizance with no monetary Bond as
well as no travel restrictions many
other defendants not former presidents
of the United States by the way
individuals without private jets with
which they could fly anywhere at any
time would have been given a monetary
Bond and may have had travel
restrictions put in place so just
something to keep in mind the associated
press also reporting and they have an
interesting drawing of what the scene in
the courtroom looked like Trump
reportedly looking glum and having his
arms crossed at many moments during this
writes Trump approached his arraignment
with characteristic bravado posting
social media broadsides against the
prosecution from inside his motorcade on
route to the courthouse and insisting
that he has done nothing wrong and was
being persecuted for political purposes
we are going to discuss that but the
article writes inside the courtroom he
sat silently scowling an arms crossed as
a lawyer entered and not guilty plea on
his behalf in a brief arraignment that
ended without him having to surrender
his passport etc etc
always in campaign mode he swiftly
pivoted from a solemn courtroom to a
festive restaurant stopping on his way
out of Miami at Versailles an iconic
Cuban spot where listen we'll talk about
this later but they sang Happy Birthday
to Trump trump turning 77 today and also
prayed over Trump which was really quite
a scene what we are going to look at
today and uh much of today's program
will be related to The Fallout from this
arrest admittedly and we will talk about
other issues as well and then tomorrow
we will move on part of today's program
is going to look at number one
why is Trump defending himself on the
basis of a different set of restrictions
the presidential records act rather than
the criminal code than that under which
he has been charged uh we are going to
discuss that why is Trump admitting to
having done many of the things that he
is accused of doing in the indictment
well it's because he thinks that that's
actually a defense of sorts and maybe
most importantly at this point in time
politically for the United States
is this
the get out of jail free card that some
Republicans have been waiting for to say
this is too much we can no longer
support this man for many republican
elected officials this is that moment
for others like Marjorie Taylor Greene
Lauren bobert
um and other people it is not and they
are steadfast steadfast in their support
and lastly what about your average Trump
supporter well Luke Beasley was on the
ground for us in Miami yesterday
interviewing a number of the several
hundred maybe most a thousand people who
came out to support Trump in Miami so we
are going to get to all of that but
let's start with Trump's own speech
after the arrest after Trump was
arrested booked and arraigned for 37
felony counts related to classified
documents that include obstruction and
other crimes
Trump flew back to his Resort and Resort
in New Jersey Bedminster and he gave a
speech in this speech Donald Trump
actually admitted to some of the crimes
he is accused of misstated the law under
which he is being prosecuted wrongly
said other people also committed the
same crimes which by the way it's not
really a defense to say other people
have also committed these crimes it's
just another form of an admission and
maybe most importantly really seemed
dejected and as though he is
extraordinarily scared which reportedly
he is really a speech for the Ages which
contained this instant classic line from
Trump I did everything right and then
me
[Laughter]
it is truly Beyond parody but it is
really an important speech because this
speech is admissible legal experts have
written overnight that even if uh Donald
Trump doesn't testify in this trial or
what may be an eventual trial
the speech he gave last night is
admissible as evidence and in last
night's speech
uh he actually
admits to much of what he is accused of
doing let's Dive Right In the Sham
indictment put forward by the Biden
Administration included stage
photographs of boxes at Mar-A-Lago many
people have asked me why
I had these boxes why did you want them
so remember he says the boxes are staged
but actually they are his boxes and now
he explains why answer in addition to
having every right under the
presidential records Act is that these
boxes were
containing all types of personal
belongings many many things shirts and
shoes and everything
as can be seen in the picture where
someone not me
I wonder who it might have been
dumped one of the very neatly arranged
boxes all over the floor
they were full of newspapers press
slippings thousands of pictures
thousands and thousands of White House
pictures
the White House photographers some are
with us today they took so many pictures
and we saved all of them and they were
in those boxes
clothing memorabilia and much much more
I hadn't had a chance to go through all
the boxes it's a long tedious job takes
a long time so understand that amidst
the bad audio and the sniffing from
Trump there are a bunch of different
defenses there it's hard to keep track
he he Declassified them when he was
president except this doesn't have to do
when he was president the FBI planted
them he called them planted boxes But
ultimately what Trump is saying is it
was my right to have those I simply
hadn't gone through them yet because I
was really busy that is an admission to
some of the critical facts that I don't
believe his lawyers are even looking to
stipulate if this eventually goes to
trial Trump digging his own hole Trump
then referring to his rights as
president of the United States but again
it's really important to understand
Trump's getting himself into more
trouble here because he is not indicted
for his conduct as president of the
United States the president enjoys this
unconstrained authority to make
decisions regarding the disposal of
documents the problem is this is not for
things Trump did as president and we
know he didn't declassify those
documents because there's audio of him
saying these are classified documents
from July of 2021 unconstrained
to make that decision neither the
archivist nor Congress has the authority
to veto the president's decision
the presidential records act does not
confer any mandatory or even
discretionary Authority on the archivist
to classify records folks under the
statute this responsibility is left
solely
to the president of the United States
think of Donald Trump was not president
when he committed the alleged acts for
which he has been indicted this is it
seems like just Trump reading stuff off
of one of the very teleprompters he
criticizes others for using it seems
like it's just more of that but legal
experts have looked at that 37 second
video clip and come away realizing Trump
is admitting to crimes and he is also
stating law
presidential records act I guess we can
call it law that is not the law under
which he is charged and Jack Smith the
special prosecutor has Trump on a
recording saying that the things he had
were still classified meaning he knew he
did not declassify them this is going to
become evidence after bemoaning the
politically motivated prosecution
against him uh in which he claims Joe
Biden was involved even though there's
no evidence Joe Biden was involved in it
Trump actually says out loud out loud if
he becomes president he will go after
the bidens for politically motivated
reasons look at this I will appoint a
real special prosecutor to go after the
most corrupt president of the history of
the United States of America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
name a special prosecutor
now you understand that people in the
background are yelling lock him up about
Joe Biden these are the people who claim
Trump wasn't given due process and they
want Biden locked up absent forget about
an indictment absent any evidence of
Criminal Intent which we will get back
to
and all others involved with the
destruction of our elections our borders
and our country itself they're
destroying our country
and when I'm re-elected and we will get
reelected we have no choice we're not
going to have a country anymore I will
totally obliterate the Deep State we
will obliterate
so Trump going conspiratorial but if you
are on the right and you are claiming
that we are a Banana Republic because
Trump was indicted Trump is straight up
saying we're gonna go after the Biden's
period full stop no due process no
evidence Trump also referred to the
documents in question as his own papers
and his own documents they are not that
I mean by law that is not what they are
these are the government's documents
these are the people's documents Trump
just like these are my documents they're
not your documents charging a former
president of the United States under the
Espionage Act of
wasn't meant for this
an act for a crime so heinous that only
the death penalty would do and
threatening me with 400 years in prison
for possessing my own presidential
papers which just about every other
president has done they are not Trump's
papers they are not Trump's papers sort
of mob-like trump attacking the wife of
special prosecutor Jack Smith just going
after his wife
he's a raging and uncontrolled Trump
hater as is his wife who also happened
to be the producer of that Michelle
Obama puff pieces total puff piece
this is the guy I've got yep going after
the wife of the prosecutor claiming that
the doj evidence was staged no other
president even those who kept far more
documents than I has ever
been even investigated let alone charged
with a crime
because the Sham indictment put forward
by the Biden Administration included
stage photographs of boxes at Mar-A-Lago
many people have asked me why
I had these boxes there is no evidence
that the photographs were staged there
is no evidence that Joe Biden did a damn
thing and then lastly moving on to Biden
and Hillary did it too which is not a
defense this Corvette is stored he's so
proud of that car
there was no security and the door was
left open most of the time it was open
all of those classified documents all of
those documents strewn all over the
floor piled up like junk
unlike me who had absolute
declassification Authority as president
Joe Biden as vice president had no
authority to declassify and no right to
possess so the normal stuff I don't have
to play the whole thing for you but
blaming Hillary and Biden for doing the
same thing isn't a defense and it's also
not true first and foremost the Hillary
Clinton circumstances there was an
investigation which concluded that there
was a complete and total lack of
Criminal Intent remember that the
indictment against Trump involves
willfully retaining these documents
refusing to give them back lying about
having them obstructing going out of his
way it also includes recordings with
alleged conversations where Trump
actually signals that he knows exactly
that those documents are classified it
is simply not an analogous situation
whatsoever to Hillary Clinton's as far
as Biden there's a special counsel
investigating that I mean we we just
haven't gotten an answer one way or the
other if Biden did something wrong
indict him for all I care but as of
right now saying Biden and Hillary did
it too is partially premature completely
Incorrect and dramatically misstates
what Trump has even been indicted for
Trump's speech will likely be evidence
against him if you can imagine it is
clear Trump is not taking advice from
his own lawyers to the extent that he
can even retain lawyers after the break
let's see what the Trump supporters
think about all of this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
we were on the ground yesterday in Miami
Florida our correspondent Luke Beasley
whose YouTube channel you can find at
davidpackman.com Luke was there and he
spoke to a Litany of trump supporters we
were trying to figure out at this point
this isn't even the first indictment
this is the second indictment serious
crimes 37 felonies the indictment is
extraordinarily detailed and tight as
Chris Christie and others have referred
to it who is still defending this guy
and we got the answer and it is really
really scary Luke doing an incredible
job the conspiracy theories that come
out of the mouths of the people still
defending the sky tell us a lot about
the cultish nature the cult members are
the ones that are left here are two
young ladies with a wild conspiracy
theory they believe Trump is still
president they are slurring badly and
they seem confused by even what they are
telling Luke listen to this what are
your thoughts about the arraignment
Candace
we believe it's a Witch Hunt but we do
believe that President Trump is actually
protected under the continuity of
government I believe he's our authentic
president and that we are watching a
movie oh really so he's the current
president of the United States I believe
that like what is Biden doing then well
Biden is um we're under continuity of
government and civil
um action okay so this is where this
happens with every one of these folks
that Luke interviews as soon as you ask
any follow-up they start to look
confused about what's coming out of
their own mouths that's the commonality
the Common Thread between all of these
and so they're showing the people in
slow motion the corruption and all the
different
uh elements uh all the different
agencies and the Dual system so they're
saying okay if you want to steal the
election which they did this is what
you're going to get so then how is Biden
doing in his role is he the president
right now no Biden is an actor but I
think Biden is has been gone a long time
that's how I feel gone dead gone dead
he's gone dead the one walking around uh
an actor
do we know who the actor is and why
would they pick an actor who looks frail
and sometimes Falls right like why would
you do that there's different ones that
play him everybody has actors but I know
it sounds so far-fetched but yeah they
say that they're going to reveal it soon
okay
who's they by the way that are gonna
reveal it this is is protecting we the
people I do believe he's actually the
king it sounds pretty crazy instead of
make America great again it's going to
be make the Earth great again right and
so for those of you who thought that
George Washington uh decided that the
U.S would not have Kings I guess you
were wrong I guess Trump is actually
King right now if you're wondering why
they aren't abandoning Trump based on
what is going on this is why these are
the people that are still defending this
guy here's another guy Luke spoke to
this guy has coveted conspiracies a
woman walks over and warns the guy that
Luke is on the left and then the guy
demands fauci be killed this is very
serious stuff that these are sick sick
people oh Colby there's a
government-made virus yeah as a
government made by
the woman says this guy's a total
liberal he's probably going to change
what you say and of course as you can
see we are playing it uninterrupted no
edits no Cuts it's like this stuff these
people don't get this stuff is so crazy
why on Earth would we edit it there's no
way to edit it to make it crazier
of course we can talk to liberals yes if
the government-made virus they said it
came from a lab if it came from a lab it
is a it's a weapon of Bio Warfare and
then they followed up this is a
depopulation operation that they're
doing my audience is less familiar so we
gotta walk through step by step by the
way a depopulation operation with a
virus that kills 0.6 of the people it
infects that's what this guy's alleging
say the creating of the virus and for
what purpose it's it's a deep stage it's
the globalist uh Bill Gates a world
economic Forum claw swap the gang from
Davos this has been in the works for a
long time was the coveted an effort to
get Trump out of office I think I think
in part in combination they've been
planning uh if you listen to uh Dr bauti
vouchi before he even entered office
said that he's gonna have to do falchi
what what is wrong with these people
falchi deal with the pandemic they've
been planning this for a long time he
said I'm going to have to deal with the
quote unquote pandemic he didn't see a
pandemic but he said there's going to be
a pandemic on his watch and there are
people have been predicted he's been
working for decades oh yeah he he you
know what Anthony belching needs to be
locked up and what caused you should be
hanging from a tree
the we wonder why the indictment doesn't
change their minds about Trump and he
says falchi should be hanging from a
tree same guy also says the FBI did
January 6. these are the people still
supporting Trump I was at January 6
January that's that's not a shocker six
was a setup by the FBI and the CIA the
cin FBI is corrupt okay wait that's
interesting so why would the FBI I'm
guessing to help Democrats did that oh
yeah so then why would the FBI in uh
consultation with or coordination with
the Democrats want to stop the
certification of Biden's win oh they
didn't stop the certification of
violence when they were four Biden's
when the FBI and the CIA are corrupt
they were behind the whole room the FBI
and CIA
in order to help Biden organized a riot
to try to hurt Biden why don't you guys
understand this it's so
obviously okay so focusing on January
6th why would the FBI want to create
January 6 and frame Trump supporters oh
because they want us to make us look
like we're white supremacist they want
us to lock us up there is half of the
January six people that are in the DC
Gulag Gulag okay uh this is sickness
this is sickness we have to just say
this is not people saying hey you know I
want to engage in the political system
so I'm going to evaluate the political
positions of the candidates and make a
decision this that's not what's going on
okay Luke actually uh randomly came
across a sort of well-known
uh uh he think he go he's called a Maga
rapper his name is Forgiato blow I don't
know if that's a given name or a
nickname Forgiato blow uh says he has a
whole new song about what's happening at
Target which he doesn't seem to actually
understand Luke tries to explain it to
him I'm here with Forgiato blue and you
recently released a song right about
Target yeah boycott Target went number
one on iTune Charts pretty cool stuff
heck yeah and what motivated you to
write that song
um I'm pretty much
the the evil agenda they're pushing on
these children right so as I was just
telling the man before it's not like an
anti-gay song you know it's an
anti-pudding children
Pride clothes with bathing suits where
you can untuck your genitals in but they
didn't do that right target did do that
no that's been like debunked 30. and on
the screen right now there are all sorts
of Articles debunking the idea of Tuck
friend Leaf clothing for kids like not
that this guy cares but it's been widely
debunked Luke is completely correct it's
not bad debunked I've been in Target
I've been held it up for adults no
there's a children's site you want to
see right now on my stuff it's only in
adult sizes not adult sizes you want to
see the children's stuff I have it yeah
remember the claim was tuck up tucking
uh uh things for children his children
just like a shirt by the way you told me
tuck it
no all the pride clothes you think any
Pride clothes are bad telling a child
hey whoever you are straight maybe
wearing a shirt my man a rainbow kid in
the third grade needs to be wearing a
shirt that says trans life matter okay
so first the claim was that they have
tuck clothes for kids to tuck genitalia
now it's just something that says trans
lives matter which of course was not the
original claim that that Forgiato blow
made then we go to a woman who seems
truly sick she gets extremely close to
Luke super super close and she seems to
be warning him about something it's hard
for me to tell you what she's warning
Luke about but it is a warning
I guess she's telling Luke that because
he's white the left the left is gonna do
something bad to him I mean he's coming
I think I do take care because this is
what makes you believe that when you're
gonna do you have a song that goes to
the university she has a song that will
explain it
sister in the University he's the last
in the least because he's he looks like
you and the last name and I'm 54 years
old I am audition that you have I have
already like an x-ray Island's older
than you this is wiser than you no no
he's older than me and I'm sick oh okay
she this woman is wiser than Luke
because she's older but Biden even
though he's older than this woman is not
wiser because he's sick
it's a Democratic Republic
all right so so this is uh you know
these are the folks that are supporting
him now and we're like oh maybe they'll
change their mind wow last one okay
here's a woman who says that Obama is
actually running the country right now
and he's running it in a racist way I
don't know
Obama's racist racist obvious
ly black you think
you think are you kidding me so Obama's
it's funny how some of these people say
it's really Trump running the country
others say it's really Obama it would be
great to get them together to argue
about who's actually running the country
died recently was uh head of the KKK for
a while and by and actually applauded
him
right so but the Obama part's
interesting to me so Obama is running
the country
in what capacity he's
he said he wanted to do six years ago he
said I'd be happy running the government
from my basement and that's what he's
doing you don't think Biden is do you
I happen to yeah you think that man is
making any decisions he doesn't even
know what day it is that's literally a
quote from Trump verbatim of him
my father
thing I want to say if you own the
mainstream media you can do anything you
want to because you're keeping the truth
from the people who owns the mainstream
media
liberal Jews oh oh no I'm a Jewish I'm a
Jewish girl so I can say that okay my
people are destroying this country they
run the Democrat Party they run
Hollywood they run the education system
are you kidding me you mentioned the
Obama's race it's because of what he's
doing in power right now what is he
doing this racism for America for but
what's the racist part of it
what he's well he's black Luke isn't
that racist enough going to the gay
community
you don't think what he's doing is
hurting them
but
homosexuality is not a race right no no
no I'm talking I'm jumping I'm jumping
around you gotta follow we can tell
you're jumping around ma'am
the racism in this country started with
Obama
so listen Luke doing the best he can
it's sort of like if I hand you a rotten
banana
and some Blades of grass and tell you to
make beef wellington or a nice chanukkah
brisket
um you're gonna struggle because I'm not
giving you the right material
uh Luke doing the absolute best he can
with some really rotten material make
sure you're subscribed to Luke's Channel
davidpackman.com Luke make sure you're
subscribed to this channel we will
continue to be on the ground
to the extent people want us to do it we
will continue to be on the ground
throughout the 2024 primary and election
all I ask of you is make sure that
you're subscribed to our audio podcast
or hit that subscribe button on YouTube
let's take a break catch our breath
collectively see if we can recover from
that and then we will continue
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
we're being super thorough today we
already looked at our correspondent Luke
Beasley's interviews on the ground in
Miami just to prove to everyone that
Luke wasn't hand selecting or
cherry-picking the craziest people let's
take just a little bit of a tour through
what we saw yesterday on corporate media
for example Fox News was also out there
doing interviews I guess this is
actually Fox Business and they found a
completely deranged guy this guy is as
deranged as anybody Luke found the
conspiracy theory this gentleman has is
that Hunter Biden started the war uh in
Ukraine
and that he actually started it five
years ago this is not us now this is not
Luke Beasley cherry picking this is Fox
businesses Griff Jenkins country the
most innocent man that's ever been in
the White House Donald J Trump the best
president we've ever had 45 47. he's
coming back this is the longest Witch
Hunt going on eight years now since he
came down the escalator do you believe
the guy's an American hero do you
believe there's a two-tier system of
justice do you believe this is unfair
obviously I don't even know how anybody
can ask that with a straight face
there's obviously a two-tier justice
system why is the Clinton crime family
running wild why is Beijing Biden and
the and the money laundering operation
that Hunter Biden started out of uh
Ukraine he started the war on Ukraine
five years ago when he was working for
barisma none of this is true but I know
I know most of you know that last last
question If by uh Trump were to get
reelected should he consider a pardon
for the Biden family absolutely not
they're a prime family you're either an
American or a Democrat these days
there's no way to be both all right
that's just as crazy as anybody that we
were able to find I mean just absolutely
no distinction we had Luke's interview
earlier in the show with the screaming
Cuban woman
um here is what this is a local station
LFA TV they found a crazy screaming
Cuban woman with many of the same ideas
we'll talk a little bit about the Cuban
American community in the context here
in a moment
it doesn't go around the world you know
getting money like the clintons like
your mamas that all of a sudden they're
preaching communism This Woman's also
holding a beer for people who aren't
watching and are only listening
mother people leave they have become
rich do you think they care about
Hispanics do you think they care about
Black Americans no they don't they
denigrade us they want us to die
crossing the border
apartment
all the political opponents was the
first one to condemn that
he goes around the world preaching about
democracy about honesty with what moral
Authority is doing that when he is doing
exactly what he's been doing Nicaragua
nothing reminds me more of the
Sandinista that the way that the
Democrats are operating in this country
there's no separation of powers they are
not treating Republicans the way that
they treat Democrats if we protest for
what they're doing to the children they
call us terrorists they think we are the
war terrorists and we are passionate
because I lost one nation okay so
there's another minute of this I won't
subject you to that there is actually a
broader thing here I've spoken to many
of you before as an argentinian-american
myself about how the vast majority of
Hispanic Americans folks from Central
and South America the vast majority of
us are indeed on the left there are some
notable except options primarily Cuban
Americans and Venezuelan Americans or
Cubans in Venezuelans who just came to
the US from those countries and it is a
tough situation because many of these
folks truly did flee horrifying regimes
in Cuba and in Venezuela there is no
doubt about that they are right to be
angry at and critical of the regimes
that have done so much damage in those
countries the problem is
after they flee those broken countries
they view anything as like if you're to
the left of John McCain or Chris
Christie essentially you are full-blown
communist Danger
and it is an unfortunate thing it seems
as though the Cuban Americans or Cubans
that we've heard from today uh certainly
are are suffering from that and it is
certainly a a sad situation
um okay Trump then went to a Cuban
restaurant uh he was Sullen and he had
his arms crossed in court then he went
straight to the Miami Cuban restaurant
Versailles which I may have been to
before although I don't I don't totally
remember it would have been about 12
years ago uh and in this restaurant it's
just a complete you know cult Fest they
start singing happy birthday to Trump
Trump's birthday is today yesterday was
the day before his birthday
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
happy birthday
37 felony counts let's sing the guy
happy birthday then in a completely
surreal kafka-esque moment supposed
Faith leaders prayed over Trump there's
a guy with a kippa or yamaka depending
on your preference he I believe is a
Cuban Jew and he you will hear him do a
little bit of Prayer in Hebrew and then
switch to Spanish as reminiscent and
nostalgic as this is for me hearing the
Hebrew mixed in with the Spanish this is
pretty horrifying stuff Faith leaders at
the Cuban restaurant praying over Trump
in Spanish there he's asking God to
protect this man with all and total
strength
give him strength in his hands give him
strength in his body he says
in the name of Jesus the the audio was a
little muddled there
[Applause]
so um that that happened and then Trump
announcing everybody having a grand old
time that he's buying food for everybody
are you ready are you ready
for everyone
[Applause]
all right I would make sure to get a
credit card up front that is for damn
sure so a crazy day in Miami but even if
the average mag at magapatamian
magadonian is not abandoning Trump
increasingly Republican elected
officials are let's discuss that next
there are still
endless gobs of Republican elected
officials who defend Trump Margery
Taylor green
you know the folks but
there are more and more Republican
elected officials who are saying this is
too much now I don't say that these
people are brave listen the guy's been
impeached twice humiliated the country
has been indicted twice is admitting to
crimes and speeches made in front of his
supporters
these aren't brave people for doing this
now but I care about the political
ramifications here is Ken Buck starting
to go in the direction of this may have
been too much how would you have done it
if you were the prosecutor then after 14
months of asking and then of course
seeing the surveillance tapes that
showed even after a subpoena
they didn't get the former president
defied a subpoena according to the
surveillance and it goes beyond that he
hid documents uh you know purposely
putting him in a shower purposely
um putting them on a stage so there
clearly is an intent uh to hide there's
an intent that he knew it he talked to
his attorneys these documents no doubt
that that it was a difficult situation
it's just a precedent from my position
my my view of searching a former
president's home uh that that is just
unseemly in in this country I don't know
what the answer is whether there were
Alternatives or not
I want to ask about
the notion of the former president being
a candidate for president again as you
said he is innocent until proven guilty
that is the way the system works and
should work but given the allegations
you just discussed some of them the
specifics of the way he allegedly
mishandled classified information would
you feel comfortable with Donald Trump
as president again well I would not feel
comfortable with a convicted felon in in
the white house so what a big boy How
brave Now understand even for Ken Buck
like he's still saying a convicted felon
certainly the allegations against Trump
wouldn't influence his vote but he is at
least drawing some Line in the Sand as
pathetic and weak I mean it's it it is a
cop-out but it's also pathetic that this
is what it takes to get them to even
revise their thoughts then Mike Pompeo
went on Fox News yesterday and he also
is saying this is extraordinarily
serious so what Donald Trump is facing
and is it right to charge him
Brian good morning great to be with you
uh two things I think are both true at
this point first if the allegations are
true and there's lots of indications
that they are President Trump had
classified documents where he shouldn't
have had them and then when given the
opportunity to return them he chose not
to do that for whatever reason that's
just Brian you talked about me having
classified documents I handled thousands
and thousands of them over my time in
Congress and then as a CI director and
Secretary of State I suppose we can all
make mistakes and get them to the wrong
place but when somebody identifies that
you got to turn them in so that's just
that's inconsistent with protecting
America's soldiers Sailors Airmen and
Marines and if the allegations are true
some of these were pretty serious
important documents now the question for
Mike Pompeo even though he's being big
and tough now is you were Secretary of
State are you saying Trump never did
anything wrong until he left the Oval
Office because that's becoming
increasingly difficult to believe from
all of these folks who say listen
everything he did as president was fine
but this one thing he did since leaving
that I'm not okay with very difficult to
believe that former uh Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan was on with CBS now he
is not a trump guy we already know that
but he is also hammering Trump very hard
from another wing of Republicans that
seem to be turning on him and this one's
National Security this one's different I
used to have these same documents myself
um as Speaker of the House so I think
this goes beyond just um some petty
thing now my guess is Trump will play
this politically pretty well and make
this weaponization argument and make
this about Joe Biden's justice
department and that's going to have some
political saliency so I don't think
Marco's wrong in saying that there's
some political sting here but I can't
help but think the weight and the
baggage of all of this and this one's
National Security this one I think we
want to nominee who's not weighed down
with so much baggage in order to win
this election all right so Paul Ryan
saying Trump is not the right guy Paul
Ryan was saying that before this second
indictment anyway Fox News senior
political critical analyst Brit Hume
actually explains the entire thing here
on the second indictment this is not an
elected official but brick Hume is sort
of the epitome of just uh put your
finger to the wind and go wherever the
Republicans want you to go he's making
it clear that this could indeed be a
moment for many Republicans to back away
from Trump what are your thoughts this
morning
well I think the two things can be true
at the same time one of them being that
there is indeed a two-tier system of
justice in which people like Hillary
Clinton uh skate while Donald Trump is
indicted for wrong and no evidence of
that at this time but okay Contin please
continue we're similar similar offense
um that does not mean however that the
indictment is not valid and serious and
its details are pretty damning and I
think that some of these politicians who
are quickly standing with Trump and and
seem not to have thoroughly read or
understood the indictment they want to
may want to back away a little bit and
and and let this let the details of this
indictment sink in and when they sink in
with the public there may be a shift in
sentiment on this that is for sure that
is for sure and we are seeing that a
couple more of these CNN reporter Manu
Raju spoke to Republican Congressman
Steve Womack and Republican Congressman
Tim Burchette and some others and many
of these are already backing away
serious concerns about anybody that has
a reckless disregard for the handling of
classified documents you're a military
guy he allegedly had National Security
information very problematic because the
reason I'm not not defending it would
you be okay with that I mean convicted
felon as your nominee
and I just have to read the conviction
but no honestly on the surface I
wouldn't that doesn't look good there
you go so a number of these Republicans
now I want to be crystal clear with you
guys I am not presenting these to you as
examples of Bravery or uh you know moral
Clarity or any of it it is simply a sign
that this may be what allows and I think
allows really is the right word allows
Insider Republican support for Trump to
publicly collapse we're going to
continue watching it what just one more
little note on this Pence now also
saying he can't defend the allegations
in the Trump indictment Pence on the New
York indictment was saying political all
this stuff
now Pence after seeing this new Federal
indictment even Pence is saying he can't
defend that so this may be a change just
imagine where we will be seven to ten
days from now
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right a couple of media stories that
I want to discuss with you there is a
very interesting realignment happening
in the wake of Tucker Carlson's firing
from Fox News and of course the Dominion
uh nearly 800 million dollar settlement
obtained from Fox as well as the firing
on CNN of CEO Chris Licht after only a
year which included a number of very
strange programming decisions a Newsweek
is now reporting MSNBC dethrones Fox
News after years-long ratings dominance
Fox news's years-long streak of raiding
dominance has ended with new data
showing it's seeding the top spot to its
rival Network MSNBC Nielsen data
regarding the week ending this past
Sunday was shared on Twitter by AJ Katz
a reporter specializing in the cable
news business according to the data
Fox's Prime Time 8 to 11 pm Eastern
viewership averaged
1.504 million the average viewership for
the more left-leaning MSNBC over the
same time time frame average
1.52 million narrowly beating out the
conservative Network that has long been
a leader in cable news viewership there
are a lot of important things to discuss
here first and foremost this is a very
small margin of victory for MSNBC and I
do want to remind everybody that I
couched this story not as I'm cheering
about MSNBC MSNBC is a corporate media
Outlet just like all the others that has
chosen a center-left very establishment
Democratic party editorial position it's
well to my right it's not super exciting
there's a media story here and I want
people to understand that it's a media
story totally separate from my
particular political views
MSNBC is being helped significantly
right now by number one the Fiasco and
disaster at Fox News in which Fox was
exposed in court for lying to their
audience in order to uh get ratings on
the basis of playing koi and in many
cases overtly supporting Donald Trump's
false claims that he won the 2020
election to further conservative talking
points to maintain access to Republicans
in power by repeating or allowing them
to repeat uncritically their talking
points that has been really bad for Fox
News the firing of Tucker Etc we then
have CNN CNN with a disastrous year with
now fired former CEO Chris Licht at the
helm and so MSNBC truly has benefited
from problems suffered by Fox News and
by CNN what this actually means for the
future of 24-hour news media remains an
open question with fragmentation of the
audience thanks to streaming and to some
degree Independent Media like our show
and so many others that are available
asynchronously online in podcast YouTube
Tick Tock Etc form
with a desire
from audiences
for a different type of presentation
that maybe feels a little less corporate
and a little more intimate in some way
this little blip in which Fox is down
and MSNBC is up may remain or it may not
as far as cable news ratings are
concerned but my prediction is that
other forms of news media and political
analysis are going to continue growing
as a share of the total news media
audience now you might say well David
you would like that right because you
benefit from that we're doing fine
already we don't need to grow anymore
everything's fine it's it's and I'm not
even saying the David packman show is
what's going to grow necessarily it's a
question about the direction of people's
tastes and appetites and there's a real
question mark now the next 18 months or
how many months do we have 5 and 12 17
months the next 17 months not even 16
and a half months leading up to the 2024
election are going to be extraordinarily
important in seeing what niches
different media Outlets choose we don't
know what fox is going to do from here
on out we also don't know what MSNBC is
going to do but very interesting
nonetheless speaking of Fox News two
just pathetic moments from last night
that I want to go over with you first
and foremost As Trump was getting ready
to speak at Bedminster after his second
arrest yesterday that is the speech in
which Trump admitted to many of the
crimes he's accused of having committed
Brian kilmead introduces Trump as the
President of the United States now I've
been there and I've defended generally
speaking referring to him as president
Donald Trump in the context of once
you've been president you keep that
title people introduce you know
President George W bush or whatever when
you have a live event and you say the
president of the United States will now
speak that is a different level
altogether listen to this insanity
let's take you the last
days
and also
the first time after being indicted on
federal charges okay I know you get to
keep the title president for life but
this is a live news event where a
reporter is tele reporter I use that
term loosely uh a guy on the camera is
telling the audience the president of
the United States will now speak it
would be useful to clarify we're talking
about former president Donald Trump if
this wasn't humiliating enough for Fox
news last night
Fox News also ended it's eight o'clock
Eastern hour with the lower third
wannabe dictator speaks at the White
House after having his political rival
arrested referring to President Joe
Biden the actual president wannabe
dictator speaks at the White House after
having his political rival arrested of
course they have still presented no
evidence whatsoever that Joe Biden has
had any even passing involvement in this
prosecution of Donald Trump at neither
the state nor the federal level that was
Fox news last night
is this part of the ratings decline
I don't know or is this part of what's
keeping the ratings where they I really
don't know what to tell you but an
insane night on Fox News as insane as
Trump's day was Fox news's night and I
don't expect this stuff to change
anytime soon we have a voicemail number
that number is
2192 David P you can call any time of
day here is our old friend Juan calling
in to say David you're wrong California
is a disaster listen to this David sir
you're talking a lot of BS when it comes
to Gavin Newsom really
and the reason I say that is because
let's see California
right how has he sold
the tents on the roads did Gavin Newsom
claim he solved homelessness I didn't
hear him claim that in his interview
with Sean Hannity the turds on the
sidewalks the stents
in the public areas where the homeless
are
he hasn't done anything with that or at
least many complaints that exist about
that
um
when he actually solves it 100 percent
then you could say okay all right so he
did solve it but he hasn't solved it so
first of all is the new standard that no
state can be considered successful if
there's any homelessness well then there
are no successful states in the United
States there's homelessness in every
state that I'm aware of I know Wyoming
only has like 500 000 people I think
there are still homeless people even in
Wyoming okay so if that's the standard
then then we can't judge any state
because every state has some
homelessness I am not like a California
um
acolyte or like a fan you know as I've
said before I've been to a number of U.S
states they almost all have good things
and things that are not so good it can't
be denied
that California's economy is one of the
most dynamic in the world if California
were a country it would be one of the
most powerful economies by itself in the
world the amount of innovation the
number of Nobel laureates the amount of
groundbreaking research in Tech and
medicine that is coming out of
California it's not coming out of I'm
not gonna you know put any particular
State on blast but it's not coming out
of a lot of other states California
operating with a budget surplus it is
expensive in California that's because
of that free market that right-wingers
love
California's state income tax is
Progressive and it goes all the way up
to 13 percent if you pay 37 percent
federally and 13 in California that's 50
and then you add property taxes and
properties are expensive in California
I'm not denying it's expensive part of
the reason it's expensive is because
there's not enough housing part of the
reason it's expensive is because a lot
of people want to live there uh
homelessness it's a major problem part
of the reason that homelessness is a
problem in California
uh is the weather is good and it's a
safe place if you have no home
that if you're stuck outside you're not
going to freeze to death and I don't
think just about any part of California
you could go up in the hills to ski
resorts I don't think that's where the
homeless people are so there are
criticisms of California but this idea
that there is a California Exodus
because of woke High tax California and
it's failing and all these different
things it is simply not the case I've
never lived in California I don't intend
to I have no personal uh horse in this
race but that is the reality we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today sign
up at joinpakman.com I want to see you
there and we will be back with a new
program tomorrow as well